[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I can't see any of you which
I'm sure you've heard today so if you're
here for I talked about how to better
use react you should probably go to the
a track so this talk is more about fun
and just silliness quickly I'm Dylan
I've been working with JavaScript since
96
I was a bit of a masochist picking it up
that early you really couldn't do that
much with it at the time I was trying to
put results of my experiments in
physical chemistry online at the time
and about eight years later I could do
that with dojo so things have changed a
lot over that time and I had my jokes
stolen by Janna in her talk this morning
because my middle name is Carl so I
thought it would be great to say that
the reason it's called Carlsbad is
because I'm bad but anyway Carlsbad has
an even more unusual history kind of
like how most things work in JavaScript
or browsers so the town was discovered
in late 1800s by someone and they
collected a water sample and it happened
to match the water quality and purity of
a spa in the Czech Republic that had the
name Carlsbad but with a k' which stands
for charles's bath which because it was
like a nice pure water city had a very
nice spa so of course it's named after
something spelled wrong with after
something that no longer has that name
and no longer has any relationship to
the original source kind of like almost
everything that happens today in
browsers so I thought that was pretty
fitting I also in searching for the logo
found this lovely other logo called
Carlsbad Tech and that reminded me of
for us his talk about how to build the
world's worst website so I thought that
was pretty funny because they probably
did not intend for it to be Carlsbad
tech instead of the Carlsbad tank also I
have never had so many mosquito bites in
my life I am always the person who
manages stand on everyone else who gets
bit and this time that's been me I've
had 50 bytes or so so I'm gonna remember
mosquito je s cough
worker Tom Jen's pixel art for us is
terrible website and a few other things
and so so far I'm having a great time
now how many are here for their first
time at je s cough raise your hands so
if I'm not blind it looks like roughly
half of you it's actually my first time
as well even though I've had a ticket
four or five times before and always had
to give it to someone else because the
world had conspired against me to attend
but I'd like to flash back to je s cough
2013 how many of you were here for that
event okay roughly ten to twenty percent
so the first je s cough a few years
before that Peter Higgins one of our
dojo contributors early on would pretty
much troll everyone as well as Kris
Williams he got into it quite well the
original creator of je s coffin he would
say you know someone would come up with
this talk about some amazing new thing
and they begged oder already did that
come on like get with it right and the
funny thing was jQuery was really
popular but dojo had like promises it
had modules and had a build system when
it had the equivalent of web components
and it had some V Thomas stuff and have
all these things like in 2007 and so
this meme came to happen but J s come
2013 was also the year that react was
first announced so it was kind of a cool
thing and here's Pete Aikens giving the
talk dojo already did that and they
managed to capture an awesome screenshot
of him making a ridiculous face so
that's why I had to show it and the meme
is dojo already did that now
unfortunately the Dadd hashtag has been
super like taken over by something
really not worth checking out I don't
remember where it is but just don't do
it but the funny thing is I was never
involved with this but I'd show up when
I'd meet people like adios Monty who's
known as like the web performance you
know God of all talks and he I show up
in Google a couple years ago in London
and he's like hey Dylan it's time for
our selfie man and he's got the dojo I
already did that you know signs for us
to take the photos so this meme has
followed me around forever and I'm
hoping that this is the year I can
change it to be react already did that
also yani a formidable he did this
really fun tweet a few months ago which
was looking back at some of the quotes
when react was first announced at je s
coffee and
it was pretty much universally panned it
was like ohmygod JSX why stop ruining
j/s people I can see this getting out of
hand quickly this is terrible so did we
really not learn anything from the PHP
days are you seriously gonna mix markup
and logic again like people just love to
react after that but it's super you know
it persevered and listened so the
question today is has react already done
that and so you could answer that by has
react one what will we say in five years
at je s Kampf 2023 who wherever that
might be
will we consider alternatives how many
of you use react as your primary
framework of choice so again more than
half which is great so we started to
work on dojo back in 2004 and we built
it over the years we came out with one
dot Oh in 2007 and we came out with two
dot Oh a few months ago and then three
dot o a couple months later because we
want to catch up to react to sixteen as
quickly as possible and but we did that
what we realized is it's time to you
know pretty much our framework existed
before es5 was finalized before es6
before type script before web components
before html5 before mobile browsers came
out so it was a pretty heavily technical
deaded framework and so we said all
right if we're not just going to use
react if we want to create our own thing
and we've primarily been focused on the
enterprise over the years what are the
things that matter to us and for us that
was developer efficiency and ergonomics
longevity of things our customers have
apps that they wrote so funny story
Apple had the Apple store running dojo
0.44 like eight years which was just we
would cringe we would beg them to update
and like now it works
all right thanks Apple unlike this
laptop which is on its fourth
replacement and a year-and-a-half thing
but at least they keep replacing it so
that's good
interoperability I'm kind of tired of
framework Wars I want things to just
work together and if any framework says
it's perfect at everything it's probably
not perfect at anything so you know when
you build something you need to be very
focused on what you're trying to do what
you're trying to achieve and what you're
trying to build and so I would say that
react has some challenges today as it
grows
because we have been at the point where
we were like a dominant framework and
now we're kind of like this unknown
framework that no one's using and the
challenges you have is as you become big
you have to support legacy you have to
support all your users because you don't
want to break them which of course is a
good thing but that makes it very
difficult to figure out what you want to
do next and reinvent yourself to stay
relevant instead of something else
coming along to replace you and I think
that's the fundamental challenge that no
one has solved in the 20 years of
JavaScript and that we invent something
and it's great and then we get fatigued
from supporting it the early
contributors get burnout they back off
and then someone else comes along with
the next big thing maybe it's view maybe
it's felt maybe it's new dojo whatever
there's I find the biggest challenge
react has today is cohesion across
project so I imagine if all of you
raised hands and shared your react
applications yeah your render functions
would look similar but I bet you might
be using different routers different
components different approaches to your
build process some of you might be using
typescript some of you might be using
flow some of you might be using vanilla
JavaScript and so on and there's not a
lot of direction around what's the right
way to build the perfect react
application and that's both its strength
and its weakness and like I said too
many choices so developer ergonomics
means many things to many people but to
me what I'm trying to get at is I want
to do things that are the right way out
of the box without having to be an
expert at every esoteric feature of the
language so by default and like you know
something that's nice and ergonomically
friendly has a consistent architecture
it doesn't feel like each package or
each piece of my framework is different
or feels different or feels inconclusive
give me some good defaults out of the
box so don't make me think if I don't
have to like if I know better than you
framework author great let me do my
thing but by default don't make me
answer 5,000 questions before I get
started and of course help me facilitate
the authoring of better code so if a
framework is getting in my way or it's
I'm having to go through great
workarounds to get it to behave
consistently I've kind of lost the
benefit of having a framework to begin
with so I'm a big fan of typescript I'm
sure that's not
prising to anyone who has met me I know
typescript gets mixed ratings in the
reactive community and I think that's
okay so and there's flow of course so
typescript I like it better because it
supports interfaces and that goes back
to that interoperability goal of hey
I've got this dependency and I want to
replace it with something else in almost
every other programming language we have
an interface definition that we know if
this object has this method and this
property in this whatever and whatever
then I can safely swap that out with
something else in JavaScript we've never
really had that
and so typescript facilitates that but
you need to define some types to then be
able to define interfaces to then be
able to say okay I can swap this thing
out with this other thing the other nice
benefit of defining types in the
ergonomic benefit there is that I can't
remember why I wrote something the way I
did two months later much less a year or
two later and so typescript and flow
sort of forced you to define what you
were thinking and so that you can
remember your own code later much less
your teammates and your colleagues also
I used to joke that there was no need
for you know people would come to dojo
and JavaScript training workshops we
would lead and they'd be like Oh kid
Dylan this is cool but I'm a Java
developer where's my autocomplete and
I'm like you're an idiot you just
remember everything in your head like
why why would you ever want autocomplete
it makes you a lazy engineer right and
that's kind of funny until you make
typos and can't find them and so on so
actually having first-class IDE support
with auto-completion is really nice
especially when you get into more
involved api's that are difficult to
remember so last year we wrote a
framework series and we did a music
theme and the idea behind it it was a
200 in some page blog series so it was
really concise and terse but basically
we looked at frameworks and asked about
a thousand questions to help you try to
evaluate a framework for you and it
wasn't about telling you which framework
to use it was to try to help you think
deeper than music selection so I used to
joke that if we picked our music like we
picked our framework we would all be
using Justin Bieber ojs right because
and that obviously was not cool in 2013
and that's definitely not cool today
so when you're choosing a framework a
need to sort of get
on the surface and dig deeper and so you
know when you look at organ aam --ax I'm
just gonna look at three things today
that are different than react and that's
view spelt and dojo and it's not because
I'm saying use those instead of react
but just a sort of a comparison so I'm
trying to figure out why view is popular
so I look at it and I think this is kind
of like react it's not necessarily
faster but I think the reason people
like it is I think there's two reasons
it's gained popularity one you can kind
of use something that's closer to HTML
so people who historically hate
JavaScript frameworks but maybe they
love to jQuery find it more approachable
and easier to get started with and yet
they can still build real applications
out of it the other reason I think is
that Evan Yu is just very good at
communicating with everyone about how
great the framework is and how to use it
and he's very passionate and it really
shows how much a strong leader of her
project can really drive adoption and
encourage growth smell I don't know how
many of you have heard of svelte I can
barely see I only see like a couple of
hands going up it's intended to be the
magical disappearing UI framework and
the idea behind it is you write some
code following some conventions that are
mostly aligned with modern standards and
you end up with something that doesn't
feel like you used a framework at all
because the build process kind of
removes the pieces you don't need and
that's really nice because by default
you're writing code that's aligned with
modern standards and doing that there
are a lot of ways to measure performance
and to me an ergonomic approach to
building applications is one that's
performant out-of-the-box so there was
an article a few months ago there's this
reference application called the real
world application and the real world
application is intended to give a more
substantial than like to do MVC look at
how you build applications and to tell
you how does a framework actually look
and how does it actually compare in the
real world and so this person took a
bunch of the examples basically took all
the client-side frameworks that were had
referenced examples embers not on there
not because he didn't like ember but
because ember did not provide an example
so and what they found was that svelt
and dojo painted much faster
than any of the other options on there
and app run I think which I hadn't heard
of before but that's kind of cool right
and then a big reason for that is the
initial bundle size for svelte dojo an
app run were really small and that's
because spelt is doing this thing where
it's basically taking all the stuff and
we're moving it at Build time that you
don't need and dojo is basically saying
I'm only going to include for your
initial render the stuff you need to
render upfront so it's doing all the
different optimizations that you might
want we also did a hacker news PWA dojo
example application and I didn't know
lighthouse could get all 100's which is
pretty cool it was pretty amazing
now the reason is we've basically
cheated by only including what you need
to actually render your app now it
sounds simple but a lot of times you're
like oh just use code splitting just use
webpack and then you go down seven
levels of hell and you never actually
get there and the idea behind a good
ergonomics solution is to say alright if
we can have to use webpack you don't
have to be a web pack expert to get the
fastest application instead we'll just
look at what you're doing and we'll
optimize it for you by default so dojos
pros you know they're one way to look at
it obviously when you decide what
framework to use you need to make your
own pros and cons lists based on your
own analysis but the idea is it's got
components they import an export to web
components it's using typescript for
ergonomics it leverages and aligns with
a bunch of modern standards rather than
trying to deviate from them or come up
with its own thing but it's also
something that's really really
straightforward and easy to make fast
and that's kind of nice so optimization
of ergonomics to me means all right if
you're gonna have build system how do
you make an application fast well you
you follow all of Alex Russell's
guidelines for pwace Alex Russell is the
Google standards evangelist who was
originally a dojo co-founder with me and
he's pretty much the get off my lawn
grandfather of JavaScript who talks
about 3G networks and really slow
Android phones and we like to troll I'm
asking him why Google won't buy I'm a
good device okay so starting out with
all the recommendations for PWA s having
a good CLI tooling that will do
what we call build time rendering which
is look at what you need to render first
and build that into the initial bundle
build that HTML and CSS and JavaScript
into that page up front to render it
follow the purple guidelines do code
splitting but the killer for us is okay
yeah we still need to support ie 11
because enterprises but if you don't
need it let's not include it so the idea
with dojo is its evergreen by default
and then you add in the polyfills and
pony fills and backports support you
need so you start out with something
really small and lean whereas dojo one
started out with everything to support
back to ie6 and no way to remove it so
obviously by flipping that around you
start out by supporting the users that
can not only new your fastest
applications first and then you add in
legacy support as an opt-in rather than
an opt-out so like I said we've really
aimed to be lean and I think any organ
AMA créme work should be focused on that
so one you need to make it easy and
consistent to write code you can use
things like typescript
you can use other tools like prettier
and so on and web pack and whatever but
the idea is organ ah mcc's or something
where you write code and you're not
having to make a lot of changes and
things are just natural and work the way
they should
so we aligned with pretty much every
modern pattern and standard that should
be followed and the reason for that is
dojo one was started in 2004 there were
no mobile devices there was no github
there was no promises there was no
module system there was no build
approach there were no web components
there were no array iteration methods
there was no for each there was no
prototype DUP behind we had to invent
all of these things and of course we
didn't invent them the right way we just
came up with a way and the problem with
that is it's really cool to innovate and
and draw things forward but then you
become incompatible with the rest of the
web and that's not good so what we've
done is we've said let's find all the
modern standards that are out there that
makes sense that helped you make a fast
application but let's not impose the
weight of those standards on you so use
them the way the language intends them
and I'll give a couple examples right
here so for example in dojo and we've
been doing this for a couple of years
now all which
or components by default our importa
bilawal as web components the idea being
I create this nice widget with dojo I
want to use it an angular application or
a react application or a view
application as long as I can get a web
component working there I can import it
or export it now web components and
custom elements are not a perfect
standard but that's sort of the first
path to interoperability between
component libraries and systems and
because dojos bundle size is so small
it's not inconceivable to think that
it's a bad idea to include dojo to be
able to do that how many of you've used
intersection observers or resize
observers I'm not seeing any hands go up
but I might just be blind by the light
at this point ok so narrow section
observer and a resize observer are new
observable style ap eyes that are in
browsers that help you know if something
has moved into view of a particular box
or if the browser has resized itself so
we used to have to do a lot of hacks to
do like infinite scrolling lists and
resize detection and we aligned with
those as well as web animations and
focus events now the reason these are
particularly interesting is in the react
world I think I'm getting ahead of
myself yeah in the react world typically
when you need to do something on a Dom
node you have to sort of go through a
bunch of Hoops to get a reference to a
node to then do something what we've
done with dojo is we've said instead of
breaking the reactive architecture with
a V Dom system we instead say you know
what those are cool things to expose
let's make them as available available
as properties that you can react to it's
basically anytime we find something
where it's like man I wish I just had a
reference to a Dom node instead of
saying here's a Dom node and breaking
the architecture we say well why and
then we provide those properties as
something you can react to I don't know
if you can see that because I can't see
it let me come out of the light yeah so
the idea here is basically you import
this meta property and this one's for an
intersection observer and then you can
just react to its properties and changes
later so rather than having to get the
node and figure out something's inside
of something else you can just use this
API and quickly work with it inside of a
render function to determine if
something is inside of something else
and then react to that so the idea is if
you
got a long page with a lot of images so
we've got a newsfeed or some other UI
like that
you don't want to load all the the
content and images down below so as the
user Scrolls then you start to prefetch
the images or prefetch the content that
you want to render it's a really nice
fast way to do that we've tried to align
with standards so instead of saying oh
let's use SAS well let's use less let's
use stylus we've aligned or something
called post CSS and what that is is it's
kind of like babble but for styling so
it takes all the CSS next properties
like the variables what I call them
something else but the variables and the
nesting of things and whatnot lets you
write CSS syntax as the spec proposes it
and then transpires it back to CSS that
works in today's browsers and then we
also do something that's kind of fun in
dojo which is you write CSS modules for
your components you write a set of
classes for that component and then we
scope them unique to that component so
we kind of break the C part of CSS so
just be called style sheets right and
then what we do is we use typescript to
compile that CSS into a typescript
module then we can import in your widget
you're like why would you do that well
it's just a list of string names but
then for that IDE experience when you go
to a theme or style your component you
can only include the class names that
have been scoped to that widget so you
don't have to go back and look at that
file you don't have to accidentally typo
the class name and wonder why things
aren't rendering the way they should
that sounds like a little tiny thing
maybe that saves you five or ten seconds
a day but that's what economics is all
about it's looking for those silly
little pain points and trying to refine
them and make them a bit better we also
support internationalization and
accessibility out of the box of all of
our components internationalization as a
spec is almost as large as all of atma
script 2000 whatever year we're in 2018
plus all the years before it's just a
very convoluted and involved spec and
it's still evolving and doing that out
of the box is really important to be
able to support that efficiently how
many of you are British or non-american
a few ok so you may have heard of this
called routing and you're probably
wondering why everyone here calls it
routing I don't know the answer
but I'm bilingual here bullet forms of
English so there we go we we've done is
we've said you know one of the benefits
of having a set of things that actually
work together so previously for years
they've said microframeworks Vennela je
s for the win and then you realize when
you build up a bunch of things you've
got 500 Meg's of NPM dependencies and
and you've just got a lot of technical
debt but you've got a lot of repetition
so knowing that hey I've got a component
system that works this way we have a
routing system that can be added after
the fact so the idea behind an ergonomic
routing system is one that's declarative
where you've written an application
you've written some components you've
managed your state in some sort of store
and then you can add routing on top of
that without having to rewrite any of
your components or any of your logic or
any of your interactions we have an
application state store it started out
very similar to redux not surprising but
we've diverged quite significantly
probably the biggest thing we don't like
about redux is it's not always clear
where and redux you're supposed to do
things where do you put your business
logic where do you do your reducers and
on and on and you ask the redux team and
they give you different answers and
sometimes their answers change over time
so the idea behind our stores we've got
three separate sort of places in a store
and it's very clear like this is where
you do your reduction style code this is
where you do your business logic and
this is where you do your
transformations and so forth and the
benefit of that is certainty and
consistency so that if you've worked
with an odor store in one application
and you come to another application from
a different company it won't feel
completely different hopefully again
this is talk is not like telling you
what we did in dojo mostly to sort of
contrast it with some of the things that
we observe and react because we do quite
a bit of work with react as well so it's
not like I'm trying to say all you react
users are wrong and you should come you
stay oh that's not the intent here just
to sort of tell you the things we do
because maybe they'll help make your
react applications better as well
joe-joe one was particularly how many of
you actually used dojo one by the way
okay
so ten twenty percent more than I
expected so that's cool so dojo one
started out with not the
testsuite I mean it was really difficult
to do the things we do today dojo to has
near 100% code coverage analysis on
everything every kind of test you can
imagine and also a set of utilities I
would say it's somewhat similar to
enzyme but for the idea is you want to
be able to test components as easily as
you can test raw dom nodes otherwise it
can become really difficult and tedious
to write tests for your widgets so a
dojo application might just use these
api so might use the core framework and
a build system and then you might use
some widgets and themes maybe the test
tooling and maybe some interoperability
the interoperability package includes
things like support for Redux so if you
have a Redux tour and you want to
experiment with the dojo application you
can do that su dojo and pretty much most
modern frameworks claim to be reactive
and that's not something react invented
like the previous talk said almost
nothing is new in javascript almost
everything is pulled from somewhere else
so the idea of reactive architectures is
not native JavaScript but these are the
things that dojo does and that pretty
much most modern frameworks do so if you
want to learn about dojo we're in a lot
of places but the key is if you're
looking at something that looks like es
3 or es5 code you're in the wrong place
that's the old dojo so just forget about
that unless you still need to support
that if you're looking for a modern
typescript framework that's where dojo
Deo comes into place how many of you
views code sandbox not a lot okay it is
the coolest online editor ever because
it was it's written by a couple of
people from the Netherlands that are in
their late teens or early 20s and it is
phenomenal so it takes Monaco which is
the editor like the actual IDE portion
of vs code but it works in a browser but
then they've taken that and they've
added like all sorts of support for
features so we can do like typescript
typescript basically error detection and
validation in the browser we can do web
pack builds on the fly we can do CSS
compilation on the fly it's just
phenomenal and they have templates for
react and angular and dojo and if you
and developed in a handful of other
frameworks so it's really quick as like
you just want to try something out or
see an example it's a great environment
to try that out so getting involved with
dojo we're part of the Jas Foundation
which is one of the other sponsors here
the Jas foundation was actually started
as a merger between the jQuery
foundation and dojo Foundation and it's
an open source foundation that the idea
is to protect a project from turning
evil so probably the biggest uproar
until about a year and a half ago with
react was that react had this weird
clause about patents that no one
understood in their licensing and until
enough people complained I think it was
WordPress that finally complained and
they changed the license but the idea
behind the foundation is to prevent
those types of issues from ever coming
up we have a lot of help online as any
good ergonomic framework should have and
then we also offer a commercial support
for people so I'll talk about the site
pen in a moment but it's not really a
big deal but so the idea behind
ergonomics is not one little thing it's
about looking at all these little pieces
and finding a way to make things better
so it's about creating applications that
are fast it's about looking for pain
points things that break the
architecture variable names package
resources bundle sizes technical debt
and just not accepting things that don't
feel right so I've seen a few talks here
where I admit I kind of got bored with
the talk and it wasn't that I'm an
[ __ ] well okay maybe I am but I
looked at it I'm like I don't like that
variable name right and that's such a
stupid reason to say I don't want to
listen to this talk but to me it's like
if you pick a variable name that feels
like it's giving me cognitive dissonance
while I'm reading it I'm just
disagreeing with you as a framework
author that this is wrong right and so
when you're caring about your users
enough to say I want to make it so you
know what I should look at every object
or class name or whatever or property
name and it should be obvious what it
does
I shouldn't have to wonder hmm I wonder
what that is about okay so react already
did that I would love that to be the new
meme from this conference so I think it
would be funny I think it'd be great to
troll the react team but you don't have
to so the question is okay in five years
will react still
here absolutely it's real going away of
course not has react heavily inspired
others so you know the question was like
all these things from dojo made their
way into standards made their way into
react in other frameworks is react doing
the same thing to other frameworks today
absolutely like without a doubt does
everything you do have to be react no I
mean why not right
so can we safely say react or did that I
would say yes now that's my own
hypothesis you can come to your own
conclusions of course and could we say
dojo already did that again we'll ask
that question now and we'll have certain
five years hopefully so to conclude work
with site pen we've been around since
2000 which is like you know a hundred
million years in JavaScript time and we
are also a remote consulting company
we've been around for a long time and we
help lots of great companies try to do
better with JavaScript the fun thing is
we actually train Facebook back in like
2008 on how to write JavaScript code
which is cool so back when they were
just PHP people who did not know how to
write good JavaScript we went in and
taught them that we helped make Facebook
fast so we've helped lots of companies
throughout the years make the web better
we also do some really fun things so if
you haven't gotten your swag bag yet get
it if you haven't looked inside of it
you'll find one of these who's open this
yet a few people this is a card game we
created called milestone mam it's not
just a deck of cards it's a deck of
cards about everything that goes wrong
in projects so the mayhem cards are the
fun cards just like the grim repo who's
the guy who pushed us to production
without testing there's the scope creep
who everyone hates and the idea is the
game is kind of played like blackjack
meets Russian roulette which is kind of
like how software development works
basically you're a project manager yes
you're a project manager trying to get
to 20 story points before your opponent
so if you come to the fireside chat
tonight bring your game and I'll show
you how to play we also run a podcast
called talk script which is kind of fun
and on the table out there there should
still be some MMS that our top script
branded they taste as good as our
content is so we've also been
interviewing a lot of the speakers here
so that content will be online in the
next couple weeks so I don't know how
much time that is but I hope it's about
the right time so thank
for coming
[Applause]